good morning
before easter we promise to the
europeans that we will do
everything possible so that they can
gain back
some normality when planning for their
well-deserved summer holidays so on
monday the european parliament and the
european
council signed the regulation for the eu
digital covet certificate it is
applicable
from the 1st of july on but if you want
to as a member state
you can sign up early voluntarily and
that's what belgium did
belgium allows as of today um
to travel with a certificate and they
issue these certificates
and here is mine
so everyone who is fully vaccinated or
tested negative or has recovered from
covet
can get one and we have right now 15
member states that have
already signed up and from the 1st of
july all
27 member states have to apply
these eu digital certificates for
the covet i am planning now to start my
tour through 27 member states for the
next generation eu
our recovery and resilience plan
and i'm very curious to test and to see
how this certificate
will work thank you